after the 150 people how do you come
down from that how do you
how do you find yourself again
well that was awesome when i got taught
caught in twitter traps
you know because i'm so burnt out by
then
from the from the talk and the
and the audience interactions and the
whole day because it's a new city it's a
new hotel it's it's a new 5 000 people
it's a new book chapter it's a whole new
horizon of ideas and it's off to another
city the next day
i'm so burnt out by then that
i'm not as good at
controlling my impulses as i might be
and twitter was a real catastrophe for
that because it would hook me and then i
couldn't
like i used to when i was working on my
book
a lot i used to call tammy and say look
you have to come and get me i can't stop
i can't stop i got tired and then i kind
of because it's part of a kind of
hypomanic focus i couldn't quit it's
like oh no i i'm still writing i need to
get away from this but i couldn't stop
and so
it's better to
to read something
a book
fiction nonfiction fiction
stephen king i was reading a lot of
stephen king when i was on tour last
time that was good i like stephen king a
lot of great narratives great and great
characterization
you know
so and
there's a familiarity about stephen
king's
writing too that it's he writes about
people you know
and so i really found that a relief
and so that was useful
you